Oh
so there's a great line that says that
sex is a disappointing answer to life's
riddle and that love is ultimately a
religious problem what we hope to get
with love is what we failed to get with
God once we dispensed with God once
Nietzsche told us that God is dead we
needed something else to believe in and
so now we we deify the other you know
when in love they're like the winds they
are our salvation she becomes the Sun
what we really hope to gain from love is
completion
it's transcendence its immortality now
it's stepping off that people-mover
that's carrying everyone else towards
death it's transcending the human
condition by merging with an incarnation
of the divine we might be saved too
ultimately when we fall in love it's a
prayer it's a sacrifice we give
ourselves and hope that this being of
light will save us from our animal
condition we can dispense from being
gods with anuses and being just gods you
know the whole purpose of the human
condition is to leave our animality
behind and become the symbolic beings
the self creating beings that we are
this recursive self-aware self creating
consciousness that is constantly
scripting and rewriting and editing its
own subjective unfolding as mind mind
constantly trumping matter we can sense
the divine within ourselves we see the
divine within ourselves the namaste and
we just reach out and and and try to get
it from the other and perhaps the
impulse to to find salvation and the
other is a mistake and perhaps the
answer is in our creativity instead I
don't know
justified